You need to know, son,
I've always loved you.
I think about you constantly.
I know I'm not a perfect dad.
I know I wasn't able to give
you everything you wanted,
just one of my deepest regrets,
but I give everything I have for you.
I still remember the day you were born.
I remember when we play catch together.
I remember when we just talked
are some of my best days.
I'm going to miss some of it.
I have watched you grow up.
I've seen you in your happiest moments
was with you and your moments of sadness.
I know your tendencies to get angry
at times. She gets self centered.
Can't make me Love Talk Dad.
You don't need to stay open.
We just are. You always taught.
You just want to know your done.
Yeah.
Okay.
What are you doing? Stop. Stop. No Dad,
two boys.
If I'm,
I believe in you.
Sign what you did in the past.
It's okay.
My love for you and not change.
There were so many sleepless
nights I waited for you.
There was hurting pain,
I'm sure you didn't see was distance
and silence that we both experience that
they can diminish my desire.
Si.
I've always loved him.
I never thought once I would leave here,
I'll never stop being
your phone to know that
and I want you to know that this is
what I want because that means you get a
second chance to live.
The second chance to love
you mean more to me than life itself.
I give my life a thousand times for you
son.
I will always love you because I'll
never stop being your father and you'll
always be my son.
Everyone.
Thanks for watching our video.
It was inspired by the
parable of the prodigal son.
It is very important to our
personal stories and our faith.
Do you want to learn more?
Click on the video commentary below
now to share this with as many people
possible.
We need your help.
We're very excited to announce a national
tour in 2014 to premiere some of our
upcoming videos.
And on this tour we'll also be sharing
our personal story behind you really,
and what inspires us to do what we do.
And that's right.
So if you want updates on a tour or if
you want us to come to your score or your
church during his 2014 tour,
please sign up at this link.
We hope to hear from you soon in JP love.